[Musica]
faccio un lavoro che impegna il mio
fisico
il mio intelletto ma anche il mio cuore
è un lavoro che richiede una
ricerca della perfezione
ed essendo perfezionista non mi arrendo
mai
se ci penso bene miss finisce
incontro tensioni interpersonali stress
ansia di prestazione
sempre
la voglia di nascondermi sotto le
coperte
alla fine della giornata è molto grande
perché spesso le cose che pianificò non
vanno come vorrei
e dunque spesso mi ritrovo senza
motivazione per imporre o forse quasi il
mio diciamo la mia scelta professionale
il mio lavoro
richiede una vastissima conoscenza del
proprio campo del po più ambiente
è un ambiente che cambia in
continuazione e imprevedibile ma è
bellissimo
infatti
il mio lavoro richiede una passione è
una voglia di cambiare le cose senza
tregua
io coltivo
calotte
ovviamente non solo
sono socia dell'azienda agricola
foradori noi siamo un'azienda a
conduzione familiare qui in piana a
mezzolombardo
siamo quattro soci tre fratelli e mia
mamma
potete capire una gran parte lo
sfinimento nervoso dovuto anche alle
dinamiche familiari in azienda
ne sanno qualcosa i nostri dipendenti
chiunque entra respira un'aria familiare
trova dietro le quinte spesso non è così
rose e fiori
noi produciamo principalmente vino per
questo siamo anche conosciuti in tutto
il mondo ma da qualche anno ci siamo
amplificati produciamo formaggi ortaggi
il mio reparto
in effetti il mio principale pensiero
quotidiano rimane la carota
allora la conosciamo tutti questa volta
avevo un ortaggio banale all'apparenza è
comunque versatile le abbiamo amato e
prezza apprezzato tutti nella nostra
vita
ma la carota la sappiamo distinguere
avete però mai preso in mano i semi
della carota probabilmente che un'auto
chi ha tentato di far crescere carote sì
i semi di arrivano da un fiore
ovviamente chi ha mai visto un fiore di
carota di voi alzi la mano
eccolo qua
ogni puntino bianco che vedete diventa
un seme
e io con circa un cucchiaio di semi più
o meno sono 10 12 grammi possiamo
produrre centinaia di chili di carote
come questa
ma prima di arrivare alla carota vera e
propria
facciamo un passo indietro
perché dovete capire che produrre carote
non è così semplice
la lavorazione del terreno e la
pianificazione
tutto comincia a dicembre
c'è chi pensa ai regali di natale io
penso alla pianificazione dell'anno
seguente
perciò
quante carte voglio produrre
quanti se mi devo ordinare della mia
varietà preferita perché sappiate che ci
sono migliaia di varietà di carote
potrei parlarne per ore ma non è questo
il punto oggi vi faccio un esempio
carote viola
all'interno sono arancioni queste forse
le vedete un po in giro ma sono rare
però
la cosa più importante da sapere che le
vostre carote sono capricciose
vogliono germinare in un terreno
perfetto perciò già la preparazione del
terreno prima di seminare un gesto quasi
maniacale sassi infestanti le infestanti
sappiamo ci sono sempre crescono molto
meglio di qualsiasi seme che mettete in
terra è una lotta continua
rincorrerle togliere dai piedi però un
altro fattore l'acqua ti dimentichi
un'unica volta di regalare la tua cara
carotina che sta germinando sotto i tuoi
piedi e passa ci offende non c'è più of
altri scherzetti
tre mesi di attesa per accoglierle per
arrivare a questo risultato
almeno tre mesi devono passare il
momento della raccolta una grande gioia
ma anche un ansia infinita
perché perché in quei tre mesi forse
qualcuno ha fatto festa i nostri cari
amici del terreno topini altri piccoli
insetti che tra forno la carota queste
cose scopriamo solo nel momento in cui
raccogliamo ma soprattutto
cos'altro può succedere
questo
le carote con i millepiedi gambe
attorcigliata abbracciate
bellissime divertentissime rendono la
nostra raccolta anche più variopinta
perché tutte le carote dritte che noia
pro capite l'ansia capite perché siamo
nervosi il momento del raccolto abbiamo
fatto tutto tutto per rendere queste
carote felici e poi
scherzetto
ramificate
ma vi siete mai accorti che queste
carote non le trovate in giro tranne nel
vostro orto nel mio o in qualche altro 8
di qualcuno
perché le carote ramificate e di questi
tipi che comunque ci fanno anche
sorridere non ne vediamo più al mercato
al supermercato sappiamo mai niente
carote dritte borse da un chilo fine
le carote storte con le gambe anche nei
liberi ai bambini
io non l'ho più vista
ma soprattutto chi ha deciso di
discriminarle chi ha deciso che queste
carte pur essendo dello stesso gusto di
quelle dritte pur essendo cresciute
nello stesso campo
non sono interessanti
chi ha deciso che c'è uno standard che
ci dice la cavate deve essere dritta
gossa perfetta facile da pelare e
soprattutto lì pronta goes così proprio
come questa
tra l'altro senza ciuffo a maggior parte
delle volte
di fatto se guardiamo i dati che
troviamo in giro solo in svizzera per
esempio questo minuscolo paese accanto a
noi
producono 60.000 tonnellate di carote
all anno 60 mila tonnellate
la svizzera cioè bisogna aveva una gran
passione per le carote è tanta la
produzione però 30 per cento di questa
produzione viene scartata per difetti
estetici graffi ammaccature
oppure durante lo smistamento le
macchine che vengono calibrate allo
standard che vedete infatti sullo
scaffale in supermercato non hanno pietà
fuori le carote che hanno un minimo
difetto di bellezza 30 per cento vuol
dire che una gran parte non viene
utilizzata almeno non finisce nel piatto
di qualcuno se vediamo sulla filiera
alimentare in generale abbiamo 45 per
cento
della produzione ortofrutticola chi
viene scartata perciò nessuno se la
mangia forse qualche insetto però non
noi
quanta gente poteva mangiarci
lasciamo a parte questa tematica molto
complessa ma arriviamo al dunque
perché voi dovete sentirvi anche offesi
voi pensate di fare una scelta quando
andate a comprare
le cose al supermercato o al mercato
contadino invece qualcuno ha già fatto
la cernita per voi ha deciso che carota
sarebbe quella giusta o quale sarebbe la
banana una favola qualsiasi cosa sullo
scaffale variopinto sembra che avete il
mondo invece è una piccola percentuale
di quello che vi sta a scegliere la
soluzione cambia pagina
sta a voi
allearvi
allearvi con chi produce ma soprattutto
abbracciare un contadino un orticoltore
chiunque sia che produce con passione
che prende cura della terra per voi
perché è nostra scelta con chi vogliamo
dialogare informarci e la nostra scelta
poter dire andare al supermercato o
andare al mercato contadino già a
trovare chi veramente può anche
condividere con voi cosa nato storto
letteralmente nell'orto
soprattutto come queste carote che si
abbracciano e questa immagine
l'abbracciare un agricoltore nel senso
proprio di
partecipare essere nel sistema di
produzione vale accorciare la filiera
perché voi avete modo di incontrarli
andando a uno spaccio aziendale per
esempio potete iscrivervi a non ha un
gas i gruppi di acquisto solidale che si
impegnano a portare la diciamo
connessione con i produttori ai
cittadini ma potete andare anche oltre
voi potete iscrivervi alla csa
comunità che supporta l'agricoltura
è un concetto abbastanza nuovo e viene
dal piuttosto degli stati uniti ma
adesso si sta diffondendo anche molto in
italia è semplicemente
il produttore io agricoltrice io o ti
coltri c'e produco per voi membri della
mia comunità che li supporta ci
incontriamo ogni settimana al punto di
reti host definito e facciamo una bella
chiacchiera su quello che fini finisce
nella vostra borsa
in questo modo vi potete attivamente
chiedermi perché ho troppo zucchine mai
fragole perché le carote sono state
quest'anno o perché sono tutte belle
dritte
ovviamente noi produttori ci impegniamo
essere perfezionisti e ci teniamo con il
cuore che la nostra produzione sia la
più bella è che sia tre volte più buona
di quello che trovate al supermercato
ma siete voi che potete
attivamente ritrovarvi a condividere le
emozioni con noi noi che mettiamo il
cuore nella nostra quotidianità per
poterla condividere con voi tramite il
prodotto ma soprattutto parlandovi e
sentendovi nostri alleati
e vi facciamo sentire con la testa in
terra il più possibile e vogliamo che
siete partecipi della filiera
grazie
[Applauso]